tamar braxton a pulls out of Dancing  with the Stars Tamar just getting out of  the car just back from the hospital  just days after tame are rushed from the  hospital to the ballroom determined to  stay in the competition  sit down see she could barely stand up  the singer has announced she's leaving  at Dancing with the Stars in an  Instagram post late Tuesday night the  real host wrote in part to quote with a  heavy heart I regret to inform you that  my season of Dancing with the Stars has  come to an end at the time of the DWTS  taping at Taylor thought she had  pneumonia but it turns out her health  issue is much more serious Tamar says  doctors have found several blood clots  in both of her lungs Tamar thanked her  fans AKA t martians for all their  support and sent big hugs and kisses to  her dance partner Val Chmerkovskiy